when you're thinking about a longer
presentation it's often best to start
with the building blocks of your
elevator pitch the who what and why for
your app and use that as a basic setup
for a story you'll have to tailor the
story to your audience but generally you
can talk about a group of people who
have a problem and then talk about how
your app addresses that problem to
tailor your story to your audience take
time to present to someone like the
people you'll be presenting to and ask
them which parts resonated with them
it's very likely they care about
different parts of your app than you do
you can make a story around the
development of your app as well your
prototyping process has given you a lot
of checkpoints along the way and a lot
of user feedback to work with and
building that story often the story will
look like we saw the problem and came up
with a solution that's your first
prototype when we tested that solution
though there were challenges pointed out
to us by users because of their feedback
we've developed our concept further and
have arrived at this shiny new prototype
when you share your current prototype
with an audience be sure to share it
natively if you're building an Android
or iOS App pass some phones around the
table with your prototype pre-installed
if you're building a web app make sure
your audience has laptops and can
interact with it themselves you'll know
you've done this right if people in the
audience explore your prototype find
something they like and show it to the
person sitting next to them